ثالث اكبر مدينه في المملكه المغربيه من
حيث عدد السكان تاسست في القرن الثاني عشر
وبنى فيها المرابطون العديد من المعالم
التاريخيه
ادرجت مدينه مراكش في قوائم اليونسكو
للتراث العالمي واعطت الجدران الحمراء
للمدينه ومختلف المباني التي شيدت من
الحجر الرملي الاحمر لقب المدينه الحمراء
لكن وضع المدينه انقلب مع زلزال بقوه نحو
سبع درجات على سلم الاختر كان مركزه في
اقليم الحوز المجاور بمثل ما تضررت بسببه
مبان ومنشات فقد كانت المواقع والمعالم
الاثريه عرضه كذلك لاضرار جغرافيا تقع
مراكش على بعد نحو 327 كيلومترا جنوب شرق
العاصمه المغربيه الرباط ومن معالمها التي
تضررت هيكل ماجد الكتبيه التاريخي ويعود
تاريخه الى القرن الثاني عشر وتعرف مئذته
التي يبلغ ارتفاعها 69 مترا باسم سقف
مراكش ولم حجم الاضرار التي لحقت به
المدينه القديمه لمراكش والتي يطلق عليها
اسم المدينه العتيقه تعرضت بدورها لاضرار
بالغه بسبب الزلزال بنيت بين عامي 71 و72
كعاصمه لدوله المرابطيه ثم للدوله
الموحديه وتضم مجموعه من الاثار وتميزها
اسورها وابوابها وكذلك المنازل التقليديه
القديمه من رياضات وغيرها بطبع مغربي قديم
متميز وقد سجلت عام 85 ضمن قائمه التراث
العالمي لليونسكو كما نشر مغاربه مقاطع
فيديو تظهر تضرر اجزاء من اسوار مراكش
الدفاعيه التاريخيه التي شيدت لاول مره في
مطلع القرن الثاني عشر وهي عباره عن جدران
ترابيه حمراء تحيط بوسط المدينه القديمه
ومدرجه على لائحه اليونسكو للتراث العالمي
تمتد اسوار مراكش على مسافه 19 كلم حول
المدينه ويصل ارتفاعها الى 19 قدما ولديها
20 بوابه و 100 برج على طولها اما في ساحه
جامع الفناء التي يرجع تاريخها الى عهد
تاسيس مدينه مراكش ويقترن بها فقد انهارت
صومعه ماجد خربوش وتضررت المحل التجاريه
لصناع التقليديين بالسوق المجاور من
المعالم التي لم تسلم من الزلزال ماجد
تيمال او المسجد الاعظم الذي يقع في اقليم
الحوز الذي يعد مركز الزلزال هو مجد
تاريخي بني في عهد الخليفه عبد المؤمن بن
علي الموحدي حوالي
1153 ميلاديه وتعرض لاضرار كبيره بسبب
الزلزال وتفاعلا مع تعرض هذه المعالم
وغيرها للاضرار والدمار قالت المديره
العامه لليونسكو ادريس انها توجهت مع بعثه
من اليونسكو لمدينه مراكش لدعم السلطات
المغربيه في حصر الاضرار والعمل على اعاده
الاعمار
[موسيقى]